[Music]  the new action-packed Tomb Raider  trailer is here and in Aviv star O'Shea  Jackson jr. and Pablo Schreiber have  high hopes for the new film are you guys  excited to see a list of the candor's  roll with Tomb Raider oh yeah yeah I  like her you like her I think she's  gonna do better than Angelina okay it's  all opinion right I noticed on your  Instagram is you have some very  interesting woman crush Wednesday oh  yeah did you grow up having a crush on  Angelina Jolie from Tomb Raider oh well  yeah I mean I love I love you Selena  virtually she messed it up like no  that's not that's not a girl I used to  know where's the Greenes it was  definitely a part of me that video game  love but yeah it was about the digital  or cross  [Music]  you